في غياب محاميه خضع الصحفي احسان القاضي
للمساءله بتهم تتعلق بطلق اموال من الخارج
وادين بالحبس المؤقت بعد اغلقه اذاعه
راديو ام وموقع ماكغاب اميرجان اخباري
امرا اثار تساؤلات في الجزائر حول تراجع
حريه الصحافه والتعبير وفق ممثل منظمه
مراسلون بلا حدود في شمال افريقيا
الان ننتظر قرار غرفه الاتهام لدى محكمه
الجزائر التي ستقوم باعطائه باصدار امرها
بعد اسبوعين اتهامات يمكن ان يكون لها
ارتباط بالماده 95 و96 من قانون العقوبات
فيما يخص التمويل الاجنبيه وتمويل
الجمعياته وبالقانون المتعلق بالتبرعات
بامن الدوله او باستقرار مؤسساتها يعاقب
في الجزائر بالسجن لمده تتراوح بين 55
سنوات وفق الماده الخامسه والتسعين من
قانون العقوباتها وفي انتظار قرار المحكمه
يواجه الصحفي احسن القاضي دعوه قضائيه
ثانيه من قبل وزاره الاتصال وذلك بسبب
الدفعه في اثار مرسى عام 2001 و 20 عن حق
حركه رشاد المصنفه ارهابيه في الجزائر في
المشاركه في الحراك الشعبي